the Pentagon gave Millions to sports
teams for paid patriotism to boost
recruitment numbers and drive positive
brand recognition the Department of
Defense paid professional sports teams
to conduct patriotic displays honoring
American soldiers for what a
congressional oversight report called
taxpayer funded DOD marketing gimmicks
while the tributes cost taxpayers at
least $10 million the full figure may
never be known since the oversight
committee discovered the startling fact
that DOD cannot accurately account for
how many contracts is awarded or how
much has been spent yes this really
happened